well russia's president vladimir putin
has played down the damage of economic
sanctions and claimed his country will
be stronger in the longer term questions
remain though is mr putin just putting
on a brave face and how much concern is
there within the kremlin about the
growing economic cost of his uh military
operation here
let's talk now to christopher steele a
former british intelligence officer who
was stationed in moscow for a number of
years thank you very much for
being uh with us christopher and you've
been
watching russia and watching putin
closer than most do you think this
moment was always going to come
hello mark thank you for having me on
the show
um i don't believe it was inevitable we
would get to this point
however i do believe that given
the perception that putin had of the
weakness and divisions in the west and
the likely western reaction to such an
adventure as this
that that is why we've got to this point
fundamentally
did you think ever think that he would
go
this far in pursuit of his goals
to be honest i didn't think he would
launch a full-scale invasion of ukraine
i thought it was highly likely that he
would launch an operation to take
lugansk and donaire's obelisks
and possibly reincorporate them into
russia
but clearly logistically and
economically and in terms of manpower
an operation on this scale is really
beyond russia and he's overreached this
time in my opinion
do you think he's miscalculated do you
miscalculated militarily in terms of the
ukrainian resistance and miscalculated
in you know terms of the
the west imposing tougher sanctions than
maybe expected
i think there are several gross
miscalculations here by putin and one of
the problems i think is when you run an
authoritarian regime like he does
and you don't welcome criticism or
debates within the leadership
then you end up with bad advice and
hearing the things you want to hear from
your advisors and i think the obvious
things here that have gone badly wrong
for the russians the performance of
their own army is not great by any
standards it wasn't either in georgia or
chechnya before that so it shouldn't
necessarily come as a surprise to us but
it's certainly not what putin was
expecting
in addition to that you've got the
brave ukrainian resistance particularly
president zielinski who putin didn't
take seriously
and he's had a bite back there
and then you've got as you say the
degree to which um western governments
have reacted this time overdue in my
opinion but nevertheless strongly and in
a united way
which has come as a surprise i'm sure to
mr putin and his advisors
what do you make of what boris johnson
has been saying to sky news uh this
evening that um
there may be
an issue here where he's paving the way
for the use of
chemical weapons do you think he would
do that
i certainly think if you look at what's
happened in syria
and you look at what's happened in
chechnya
and of course what happened on our own
streets in salisbury um i wouldn't rule
it out at all and i think that
as the russian army becomes bogged down
and more desperate and clearly not
realizing its objectives militarily you
are likely to see
more indiscriminate killing
and bombardment and possibly the use of
a weapon as you describe it
and what do you think of the way nato is
dealing with this do you think that nato
should be
you know
publicly setting down setting out its
red lines
i think nato has probably set down some
of the red lines although clearly there
are war crimes going on in ukraine as we
speak and those need to be brought to
justice in due course in the future
i think that it's very important that
militarily russia fails in this
operation and i think it will only fail
if we continue to supply
handheld weapons anti-tank weapons
anti-aircraft weapons
on a very large scale and indeed provide
economic support to the ukrainian
government and its forces
do you think this is a different
vladimir putin to
the leader that you saw
um a few years ago
fundamentally not
i think putin's family and his
background was forged by the siege of
leningrad in the second world war where
one million people died
and i don't think that the culture that
he comes out of allows him to escape
from a kind of fear of encirclement
and a zero-sum view of world politics
and world affairs
and also i would argue a lack of
understanding of economy because economy
in the end is what will stop russia on
its tracks and what will probably lead
to the fall of this regime sooner rather
than later
because of the weakness of russia
economically russia has an economy which
is a tenth the size of just the eu let
alone the us
as well and that will in the end tell i
believe
what are the chances do you think
christopher of someone in the kremlin
someone who gets close to vladimir putin
um
taking him out putting an end to this is
that at all a possibility
i certainly think it's a possibility
it's happened in russia before obviously
it happened to nikita khrushchev
after his failure at the cuban missile
crisis
i think it's certainly a possibility i
suspect that putin is very well
protected and paranoid about the people
he has physically around him but i still
suspect that this is we've seen the high
water mark of putinism and that this
overreached adventure and despicable
operation in ukraine will eventually
lead to his downfall and that of the
regime
and if it's not someone in the kremlin
what is the possibility of
you know the people
turning against him that the protests
just gather in pace so much so that um
it becomes very difficult for putin to
carry on i assume that you know being a
kind of dictatorship that's not going to
happen
i
don't think it will be decisive but i
think it will probably be a factor as
the economy is squeezed the sanctions
start to bite which they certainly will
and as people's living standards start
to fall there will be increased protests
on the streets of moscow and petersburg
and other cities and i think that will
play in to probably an elite attempt to
remove putin in due course
and just finally
30 seconds or so how do you see this
playing out
does
does putin come out you know from this
does he survive this do you think
i think putin can't be resurrected as it
were in the international community i
don't see him
surviving this in the long term i think
we've gone over a watershed here
and my view is however that in the short
term we're going to see probably
increased brutality from russian forces
and atrocities in ukraine sadly but in
the longer term the economy and the
sanctions and his isolation both
cultural and economic in the world will
tell and will lead to a change of regime
in russia i certainly hope so
christopher thank you very much indeed